a rainbow nation at peace with itself
and the world
I'm going racial divide and posted
contents and this is all and this is the
racial tensions of residents and Harris
divisions are very old
[Music]
widespread poverty and clearing in fact
started a living person in a coffin
against his real underclass of kin
[Music]
[Music]
I wish that I could change what is
happening to my country I'm a musician
and this is how I translate my ideas and
my dreams into this world
[Music]
I grew up in Soweto so where to is the
largest township in Africa growing up
into a - there was a lot of poverty and
it still alot of now there were few
opportunities for me to escape that
poverty
come around me that [ __ ] suppose my
family still living so it's a no good
hanukkah's all good
my grandmother always wanted to open up
a jazz club but her dreams were never
realized because of apartheid but she
had tons of Records we started
rehearsing at like 2 p.m. to 3 p.m. PM
PM the other guys that arrested not a
year in the past so where to was a
horrible place to live in because of the
violence that was inflicted on the
people that lived in
[Applause]
and the violence was not just physical
violence poverty itself is inherited
violence what's the picture grandmother
this is probably 1950s yeah all the
girls of their heads shaved short hair
or shifty that's all so even for the
girls even for the girls just work from
me I need to pinky to lovey-lovey was
six kilometres where they not allowed to
wear shoes or acting money I think money
much of what they had to do back then
was a struggle you see the trauma in
them even today this was exactly 94 in
his when the first elections yeah I was
counting votes 1984 counting votes
obviously that week things change the
whole country changed the mood was so
even if I be everywhere
[Music]
I was very lucky with the childhood that
I had I grew up with privileges that
many others didn't have I first
discovered music from very very young
age as my mom is the pianist now I
absolutely love music it's a big passion
of mine you know who you're not bye-bye
welcomers on the instrument they just
forces little he said cars unstuck
I serve the say that Austin and I were
ahead foresters escena de insula sealed
by Austin who addresses I honestly
believe that music can bring people
together music is a universal language
progression to be honest my close
friends are the same races me I don't
think it's something that's
intentionally done
we are friends along racial lines
and that's why we still have
segregationist cities
[Music]
I think when people are not integrated
it can definitely definitely lead to
prejudices between the races because you
don't really know those people and you
don't you don't understand them
as we can see from history prejudice
leads to inequality and this is a fact
that we cannot dispute South Africa is
still one of the most unequal societies
in the world
[Music]
the majority of our country's population
is is very very well thank you Father
for futsal at the phones for citrus most
part of the owner I finally in from for
breathalyzer
the sewer boy eloquence at the very 1717
knee well yeah Miyagi 17 October October
mmm so it would be the whole team that
went for the toe
oh that is awesome yeah that whole
Orchestra Antonio Cape Town Prefontaine
margin every London see from biology but
think is stone 810 color
yes though a libretto means that
bonagora produces what do you listen to
come this
in green Quezada in Auckland an
orchestra the kids at home local John
walks of life baby look and anyway one
guide suits
[Music]
I heard about the orchestra quite a few
years ago and I heard that they went on
tour going to Europe has been a dream of
mine for a very really long time
yeah t-men guitar Caillou began to do it
I was lucky to go to a school that had
some classical instruments I was
introduced to the channel and it was
love at first sight very few people had
this opportunity in Soviet
[Music]
the cello changed everything the
orchestras in South Africa have always
been dominated by white musicians and I
never imagined myself being part of one
to be really honest when I went to the
orchestra it was possibly the first time
I'd been in a space where there were
really a lot of people from really
different backgrounds
I think this orchestra is very very
special
okay so let's go back to the beginning I
thought there's a lot of a lot of the
things a lot of good things from from
yesterday thank you I think we can do
this now and keep going one two
[Music]
so where there's not where this
crescendo starts four bars before in my
opinion I think the members of an
orchestra have to be friends to make it
work all right thank you thank you thank
you 15 minutes
if you have that bond with your fellow
musicians and you were all making the
same music together it's much easier to
achieve that goal of creating a really
good performance have you ever heard
this music so mentor number five
remember you need to be dressed up as a
crowd it's when you start knowing each
other then it the fears of who you are
and assumptions disappear this is so
where to this whole table I feel almost
right in the center oh really
my great-great-grandmother was born in
swordsman like 1907 when they moved to
Soweto you could actually see a bit of
her antelopes
I mean if you go now you can see when we
want to break racial lines
you must engage each other beyond a
group of people go for the individual I
mean and see how we work together see
the energy between us and how there's
[ __ ] love yeah unfortunately it's
incredibly hard to get funding for the
orchestra there are people who don't
want the situation in this country to
change
[Music]
my biggest worry for South Africa is
that we lose all this positive energy
that we had in 1994 after the elections
the collective spirit of ending an
injustice system
South Africa is in the crossroads where
even Mandela's legacy is disputed
[Music]
this rainbow nation might just be alive
[Music]
I'm a musician you know I'm trying to
positively change my country through
music
[Music]
[Music]
sometimes you never saw if people
actually will come to the concert
whenever we have these concerts I never
know you know if we can have the same
opportunity again yeah I have nervous
[Music]
it still is below
I initially joined the orchestra because
I've always wanted to go to Europe but I
think what I got from it it's so much
more journey the Miyagi Orchestra has
absolutely changed everything for me it
has grown beyond music
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
when people come together and they
really try and work these out and they
have hope then that is when this country
will change
[Music]
music in essence is a collectible every
voice is equal and the voice should be
unhappy
[Music]
tolerance is not enough we need to
really love each other to become just
one stop
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
there is no is the road to freedom
none of us catching alone Thank You
chief
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]